hey everybody welcome to a new series in
planet coaster which I probably
shouldn't start because I've got so many
running already but I'm gonna try my
best explain why I'm doing this and
first I just want to give a very quick
explanation what I'm doing here as I'm
trying to give the other explanation
basically this is a layout for an
intimate mega lights that I'm working on
with the four by the four meter method
for some reason I decided to try and
boot that up again but it's not really
the focus of this video the real reason
why I'm making this video and the real
reason why I'm starting new small series
even if that wasn't my own intention or
my own idea is because I've got an email
from frontier a few days back and that
email you might already know what it's
about
in a few days or actually tomorrow from
the time that this video is coming out
on July the 10th a new updates and DLC
on planet coaster is coming out which is
the vintage pack and frontier basically
did something which they haven't done so
far but which I'm actually really glad
that they did they held an embargo and
gave a bunch of youtubers and streamers
early access into the updates in order
to prepare and make videos and do live
streams before it comes out just to
figure out some stuff and try to give
people a taste and also raise awareness
for the fact that the update is coming
out so here you go I suppose if you
didn't already know the vintage pack is
coming out on July the 10th and it's
gonna have a lots of new stuff in it and
this is really what's something that
concerned me after my initial hype of
everything that was new then I saw in
the pack kind of died down because as
much as I love the pack and honestly it
might just be my favorite pack so far
there's a lot of things that are really
useful for me personally that I've
always wanted to see in the game
including more flowers more building
elements some really Arabic and Moorish
architectural elements but also some
really great pieces which I didn't
expect earlier which are the focus of
this video which is supports pieces for
rollercoasters and because I saw that or
I should say because the lady signer
told me about those support pieces and
was the first one to show them off to me
and I've noticed that some other people
who have the early exes didn't notice
right away that these support pieces
were there because they're not really
part of the vintage pack they're not
really part of the vintage theme if you
will but they're still included in the
game for some reason and it makes me
insanely happy because it's partly
something that is really power player
focused it's not really for the average
player because most people are not going
to want to custom support their coasters
it's kind of something for the silver at
of this world I suppose at least that's
what I was thinking they were going for
but also it shows that they're kind of
taking you know not just the vintage
direction with this pack they're adding
quite a bit for everyone it's not just
all vintage you've got these other
details and little tidbits here and
there as well like the the Moorish
elements and the the new flowers and
stuff like that and that is on top of
the the bigger changes in the game that
are coming as well like the vending
machines and the fact that you now get
camera filters and all that kind of
stuff so my concern was really how do I
make a video about this update and I
figured I would do it the only way I
could just launch up the game and try to
build stuff and see where it goes and
really try to force myself to use the
new elements as much as possible but
also kind of in a unique way to show off
their unique purpose so this first
episode is really going to be all about
those custom supports I'm not sure if
anybody else is going to do that and
what I am sure of is that many youtubers
like the ladies I know a geek ISM and
all of those people are gonna make all
kinds of videos where they show the new
pieces and everything like that but I'm
not quite sure if anybody is going to
give a first view of these support
pieces and what you can actually use
them for
not to mention actually test these
pieces and see how good they really are
because it's it's kind of new to this
game and for me it's really interesting
because it's something that I've done so
much in the past because I used to play
a lot of rollercoaster kanthri
and in this community doing custom
supports for your coasters was pretty
much the default way to go about making
coasters because the in-game support
were really quite bad and really half
the the creativity was all in the
supporting of coasters and ever since
planet coaster and the pretty good
automated supports that you get in this
game that the whole contest has sort of
died down and I'm really curious to see
how much these new custom supports in
the game can actually bring that sort of
culture up again so this video is all
about those custom sports and kind of
testing them and seeing how good they
really are seeing how user-friendly they
are and if you're if they're actually
usable that's all really before that
though I decided to just build a quick
test coaster and that's where things
kind of went wrong for me that's why I
have to give my explanation on why this
is a series and not just a one-off video
this was supposed to be a one-off video
I was supposed to just whip up a layouts
in like 1 hour or something somewhere
along the way I decided then I would use
these 4 meter methods to make my coaster
and somewhere along that way I decided
that I would do my best to make the
perfect layouts for an intimate mega
lights according to my personal tastes
at least and somewhere along that way
the whole process of creating this
layout took hours upon hours and my
entire afternoon of the one day that I
had to make a video before the embargo
deadline so this is all I have to show a
coaster layout creation and custom
supports that said this is probably one
of my favorite courses that I've ever
made in this game it is quite smooth and
I actually quite like the layout it's
based on the intimate mega light
standard layout so it's not really all
my creativity but it's with some
personal flourishes that I kind of
prefer in any case it's time to get into
the custom supports and this is the real
deal on what this video is mostly about
so in the well it's it's the sort of
support section of the building section
it is it is a little bit of a weird
thing because where do you put these
supports really they're not really a
building they're not really scenery
either but this is where they are at
least for the moment and
the packs consist of a number of
different support packs that kind of
belong together and they have supports
of different widths and different kind
of flanges and footers for each one but
I think there's a loan that you can mix
and match with these things you can
probably put some different footers on
some different supports and I think it
works really well for different coaster
sizes and types as well some of these
supports really kind of seem like B&M
supports some of them are really thick
and large so you could use them on
really big coaster as well some of them
are quite small so they're more fit for
the smaller coasters and in this case
I'm building an intimate mega lights so
I wanted to follow the look of the
intimate mega light supports and two of
the biggest game changes I think here
are the the flanges and the footers
because of the flanges you can actually
get that detailed look of a realistic
supports that you can really do before
some of these some of these have been
built by people before where they would
make the flange out of lots of arts
pieces which is really inconvenient
annoying and it legs up your computer
and lots so these flanges are definitely
a game saver when it comes to that and
the footers are also quite nice because
it's a similar case if you wanted to
make a footer with just the old in game
pieces you'd need a lot of pieces and it
wouldn't quite look on points but these
ones actually do kind of look like the
real intimate footers I'm not sure if
that was the intention or what these
supports were based on but I think by
making a mixture of these different
supports you can make quite realistic
intamin or BM or bakoma
style supports for a lot of your
coasters so really when it comes to that
detailing
I think this experiment really is quite
a success as you can see I'm not using
the standard supports pieces or the
standard track connector pieces I'm just
using two smaller beams from the art
pieces and then sticking a flange
between them which works more or less as
well that is basically what an intimate
connector looks like for those who
aren't as much into rollercoaster
supporting because funnily enough I'm
religious basing all of this on my
roller coaster cone three knowledge from
years ago all the different coaster
manufacturers have noticeably different
supports and even different connectors
the intimate connectors have usually
round beams that really go into these
triangular tracks whereas the bnm
connector is a very square connectors
with round flanges that supports to the
that connect to the supports so there's
really kind of a distinctive look to
each one but I think with these in-game
pieces you can actually quite well
recreates that look for each company
even if you have to put some effort into
it sometimes and other times you can
really just copy some of your earlier
supports as I'm doing here maybe make a
small of a few small adjustments but
it's quite easy really to build these
things and it didn't take all that long
and I have to say this was a lot easier
and a lot better than any of the
supports that I've done in rollercoaster
country so it's definitely on a whole
nother level here and it's actually
being kind of fun to do this entire
custom supporting again now I've done it
a little bit on grapefruits but even
that was a little bit less realistic it
was just art pieces and the old art
pieces were either a little bit too thin
or a little bit too thick to be
realistic coastal supports but with
these new support pieces you can pretty
much get guarantee that you have one
support piece which is the right
thickness for the coaster type that
you're using and I also think that the
flanges make quite a huge difference
because not only do they look slightly
better and add some detail to the
supports it is just more of a realistic
thing to add to them realistically
supports don't just come in one piece
they come in all these different pieces
like one big modular IKEA furniture sets
and the flanges are where all of those
different beams connects and all of the
different connecting pieces all come
together to be four to form these four
supports so having all of those bolts to
the sides of your supports is really
something that that adds a bit of
realism to the look of the structures so
I'm really glad that those are in the
game now and I think it actually looks
quite fantastic
not to mention that these flanges are
just working superbly as track connector
pieces so altogether I am actually
really happy with how this turned out
now for the first time ever I suppose in
a planet coaster series I think I could
get a little bit into what the entire
philosophy is behind the supporting
structures instead of as I usually say
the philosophy behind my architecture so
what I'm mostly borrowing this off of is
the existing mega Lites support
structure which especially for the lift
Hill is quite a signature kind of
support style it has these vertical
beams with them one diagonal beam
sticking out from it and on the lift
hill supports it has a bunch of
horizontal beams and cross beams
supporting the whole thing so
essentially you can support the whole
lift Hill with only a few footers in the
ground and have this whole mess I have
round iron beams above that and then
there's the two airtime Hills that
follow the lift Hill which are basically
the same as the existing mega lights
only slightly larger and slightly
changed the banking is slightly
different because I like that really
twisted airtime but I'm following
basically the same supports for then as
well one vertical supports coming out
from the connector and then one diagonal
supports support that don't play
drinking games with the word supports in
this video so yeah that's that's kind of
the the very standard design of these
and then after that you might have
noticed that after those two big airtime
Hills you jump into these curves with
between all of the curves a little hill
going up and down and personally these
are my favorite parts of the instrument
mega lights to be fair I've only been on
one intimate mega lights which is cour
semi but they're all more or less the
same aside from some very small changes
and really my favorite part in these is
is those three hills where you twist
from one side to the other because you
get very twisted airtime like while you
are making
that hill while you're making that
parabola going from up to down
you're also twisting from the left to
the right and from the right to the left
so it's not only sort of pulling you out
of your seats but it's also pulling you
out of your seats and at the same time
kind of rotating you it's a really cool
in the strange sensation and honestly I
didn't expect to like it that much
before I wrote , semi for the first time
but it's actually one of my favorite
coasters in the world now that I've ever
been on and I really love that twist at
air time so I'm bringing that back for
this coaster as well it's the same three
curves with three hills in between them
only with a small difference is that the
hills are ever so slightly lower so the
airtime should be a little bit stronger
and it should retain a little bit more
of its speed and just altogether be is
slightly more intense and it is really
after these three curves that most of
the changes in the layouts occur you can
see a over-banked curve right there
which isn't in the original layouts in
the original layouts that is just a
simple flat curve over the ground after
that it jumps into two bunny hops which
is the same as the original layout but
where in the original layout it goes
into another small hill and then into a
long drawn-out curve after those two
bunny hops in this one I decided to
change that and just go straight into a
curve after the bunny hops to the rights
and have a quick s Bend with some nice
positive g-forces
at the end with another curve finishing
it up into the lift Hill so this layout
is very similar to the existing mega
Lite layouts it's only ever so slightly
larger faster and with less downtime if
you will like some of the more calm
moments of the layouts I've been
replaced by some other sensations like
the pretty intense g-forces that you'll
get in that over-banked curve and then
the s-curve at the end so you have a
little bit more variation in the layouts
and also make the layouts as a whole
slightly more intense and this is also
why it's probably one of my favorite
layouts that I've made in planet coaster
although that is really just personal
preference because I'm just kind of
looking at how this thing would ride
where it's actually a real coaster in
real life because I love the mega lights
and I just thought that the few moments
of downtime could be a little bit better
and a little bit more intense and that's
basically what I've done in this thing
and I've made the airtime slightly more
intense every every Hill almost on this
thing is at least minus one negative
cheese which means that every Hill is
ejector airtime and it's gonna basically
throw you out of your seats pretty
violently so it's pretty pretty heavy
layouts for being not so huge a coaster
it's really not that big it is not quite
a hyper coaster or anything like that
I believe I measured it to be about 41
meters tall which is pretty small but
really for that size this thing is
really intense now this thing is called
the Moorish intamin as you might have
noticed because I wanted to try some of
the Moorish elements and the Arabian
kind of team in the next video because I
really want to try those architectural
elements I just didn't get to it in this
video because things have been taking so
long with the four meter method and all
of that stuff but I promise I'll get to
it next time I'm gonna try to finish all
of the scenery for this thing quite
quickly it isn't going to be as in
detail as my usual project but I still
want to make sure that I try to use as
much of the new pieces as possible and
try to experiment a little bit with them
as we go now with that all said I hope
you guys enjoyed this video and there's
a little bit of a different take and
very much a coaster focused video which
I haven't done in a long time and I'll
leave you with a few off-road shots and
an on-ride POV of the coaster see you
next time guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you